let's go instead to tyler from st louis
tyler you're on the air
hello david um so
i don't know exactly the subject of
everything but uh
i was wondering is there anything to the
arguments
that uh universal healthcare would lead
to
lower quality of healthcare
well that's what i tend to hear but i
never explained
never explain causal relationships there
the best
the best i've the best stuff i've read
about this
is uh from the late oovey reinhardt
who wrote that basically imagine a
triangle
you're familiar with a triangle i'm sure
and you know that it has
three corners does that make sense
the three corners of healthcare are cost
quality and access and that
no matter what system you support
you are basically picking a midpoint
between those three
so for example if you want to make it
really cheap
and give it to everybody uh quality is
going to go down now it could still be
better quality than we have and we might
still be spending more you know like we
spend a lot so
this is just theoretical i'm building
the theoretical framework so if you want
to give it to everybody and make it
cheap there's going to be some sacrifice
in terms of quality all else being equal
if you want to make it cheap and really
good
then to some degree you have to restrict
access
you understand so everything is kind of
a balancing act and so
when we talk about universal healthcare
if you want it to be
universal um and you want it to be
really good
it's just going to be more expensive now
a lot of people will hear me say this
and they'll say david that's not true
look at how much we spend on medical
billing and
there's profit motive and then there's
all these levels of bureaucracy and then
because some people don't have health
insurance hospitals raise
prices and make them artificially high
that's all completely true
that's absolutely and completely true
the i'm just saying
all else being equal if you want to make
it
high quality and available to everybody
it's going to cost some money and it may
be
it may be a reasonable amount of money
for example i would be okay with it
being expensive
if we've actually eliminated all of the
waste and the bureaucracy and all of
these things
it's just as this a decision as a
society that we have to make and so
that's the sort of triangle you have to
think of it's all just picking a point
between those three
corners and saying here is where we want
to be
okay uh thank you and uh by the way if
you ever end up in st
louis make sure to try st louis style
pizza
is that a thing or is that a joke well
it's a thing it's really good
what it what's what are the
characteristics so
it has its own we have our own cheese
called provel
okay and it's like it's like a mix of
provolone and swiss and
american cheese um
people say it's an acquired taste but i
don't know i've always liked it
and well i'm up for trying it yeah and
then it's cut
it's cut into squares and i don't know
about that
it's got a very it's got a very thin
like cracker-like crust
okay all right well yeah if i next time
i'm in st louis i will check that out
all right see ya all right my friend
thank you for the call appreciate it
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid 19 and they're
giving my audience 20 percent off
snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over 150 dollars you can
get there by going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david